the social media app tip talk came under
very intense scrutiny yesterday on
Capitol Hill lawmakers on both sides of
the aisle grilled and grilled is the
word here Grill the company CEO on how
the company protects Americans private
information from Chinese government
surveillance now some support a total
ban of this app calling it a risk to U.S
national security Nicole Killian has
more from Capitol Hill
tick tock's chief executive was met with
intense skepticism on Capitol Hill
Thursday over the app security and
privacy practices we do not trust Tick
Tock will ever Embrace American values
shows each you tried to dispel lawmakers
concerns about China's access to
American data since its parent company
bike dance is based in Beijing by dance
is not owned or controlled by the
Chinese government but when pressed
repeatedly Dubai dance employees in
Beijing have access to American data we
have employees in China so yes has fight
dance spied on American citizens I don't
think that spying is the right way to
describe it committee members argue the
platform remains a national security
threat you damn well know that you
cannot protect the data and security of
this committee or the 150 million users
of your app because it is an extension
of the CCP Chu said the company is
working to build a firewalled up project
Tech taxes to store and protect user
data in the U.S I have seen no evidence
that the Chinese government has access
to that data I find that actually
Preposterous the panel also broke what
safeguards the app has to Shield teens
from harmful content Tick Tock could be
designed to minimize the harm
to kids but a decision was made
to aggressively addict kids in the name
of profits after more than five hours
many weren't satisfied he was completely
big that's not sufficient in a statement
Tick Tock fired back saying the day was
dominated by political grandstanding hi
everyone it's Joe here choose testimony
comes at a challenging time for the
platform which boasts more than 150
million American users and more than a
billion worldwide
[Music]
its parent company bike dance is under
investigation by the Department of
Justice for alleged spying and the Biden
Administration has threatened to ban
Tick-Tock unless it divests while
Congress pledges more action
the chair of the committee says she
plans to move quickly on legislation
involving Tick-Tock in response to the
CEO's testimony this morning Chinese
leaders announced that China has never
nor would it ever ask any company for
data or intelligence in foreign
countries back to you Tony yeah
lawmakers saying that's hard to believe
Nicole thank you very much